>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Good morning or afternoon.
I'm not quite sure
which one it is, but --
My name is Betsy Peterson
and I'm the Director
of the American Folk Life Center
here at the Library of Congress,
and on behalf of all the staff
I want to welcome you here today
for the latest in our Botkin,
Benjamin Botkin Lecture Series
which is an opportunity for
the American Folk Life Center
to offer the very best and latest
in cultural heritage, oral history,
ethnomusicology, and
folk life scholarship,
and share that with all of you.
The lecture series here allows
us to do a couple of things,
not only share all of this great
information but each lecture
that is given here is videotaped
and will eventually be webcast
so that researchers around the world
and future researchers can
hear and learn from this.
And it will become a
permanent part of our archive.
So with that said, if you
could turn off any cell phones
or any other electronic devices
I would greatly appreciate it.
Today we are really
thrilled to be able
to welcome a distinguished
colleague, Carol Silverman,
who's an award-winning Professor of
Cultural Anthropology and Folklore
at the University of
Oregon in Eugene.
Dr. Silverman has been involved
with Balkan music and culture
for over 30 years as a researcher,
teacher, activist, and performer.
She has focused on Bulgaria
and Macedonia as well
as on Balkan Romani immigrants to
North American and Western Europe.
Her work explores the relationship
among politics, ethnicity, ritual,
music, and gender as you can see
from the -- her most recent book,
Romani Roots Cultural Politics
and Balkan Music in Diaspora ,
which is -- will be the topic
of the lecture here today.
It was published in 2012
by Oxford University Press
and it has won high
praise from all quarters,
and received the prestigious
Allan Marion Book Prize
from the Society for
Ethnomusicology.
Over the years Carol Silverman's
research has been supported
by fellowships from the
Guggenheim Foundation, from NEH,
ACLS or the American Council
for Learned Societies,
and many other foundations.
And in 2014 she was
inducted as a Fellow
of the American Folklore Society.
She is also a professional
performer in her own right.
I know some of you may
have seen her yesterday.
She provided some introductions
for our concert of Esma Redzepova.
But Carol also teachers Balkan
music and works with the NGO Voice
of Roma based in California,
and I guess now
in Berlin, Germany as well.
She has performed with numerous
musical groups including Zhenska
Pesna [phonetic] and Trio Slavej.
And she's recorded with
the Yuri Yunakov Ensemble.
So, immediately following today's
talk we will have a short Question
and Answer period, and then
Dr. Silverman will be outside
in the foyer and can sign books.
But I want to encourage
you to go out there.
Please buy one of the book
and talk with her some more.
So with that said, please join
me in welcoming Carol Silverman.
[ Applause ]
>> Carol Silverman: Thank you so
much Betsy Peterson, Nancy Groce,
Thea Austen, John Gold,
and all the staff
at the American Folklife
Center, for inviting me here.
Actually, I'm not really going to
talk about my book because I'm going
to be talking about my newer
research that came out of the book.
So whereas the book
focused more on Romani music
in their own communities,
I'm actually talking
about the popularization of
Romani music among non-Roma
and what happens when
appropriation arises,
what happens when the
management of Romani music is
in the hands of non-Roma.
So you can see by my title
I've put "Gypsy" for a --
in quotes very prominently.
And that's because I only use it,
actually, as a marketing term.
Roma use the word "Gypsy" --
Roma do not use the word "Gypsy"
if there are Romani speaking when
they're speaking their own language.
And so I'll be talking about
names a little bit later.
"Gypsy" is an outsider term,
sometimes used by insiders,
but Romani-speaking Roma
would prefer the word "Roma."
It means a person in their language.
And in the English language
"Gypsy" is an ethnic slur.
It means to swindle or to cheat
somebody, like he gypped me.
So I avoid that term.
But I can't when I'm studying the
marketing of music because it's
under the rubric "Gypsy" music.
So remember the quotes.
So today I'm going to be talking
about the pathways of Romani music
into commercial markets, DJs,
celebrities, production houses
around the world, festivals.
For example, this festival that I
studied in Belgium that continues --
actually, it's happening right
now, the Balkan Traffic Festival,
that actually under the rubric
"Balkan" has about 90% Romani music.
So these days the word "Balkan"
and "Gypsy" are starting
to mean the same thing even
though Romani music has many,
many genres that are in
Balkan and many regions,
and Balkan music has many
genres that aren't Romani.
So there's a collapsing then of sort
of the market into a singular path.
This festival featured
three Balkan brass bands,
and that's another
collapsing at this moment
because the most popular
Balkan Roman music genre
in popularity is brass
music which is, again,
a tiny part of Balkan Romani
music in its entirety.
But for outside audiences it seems
like all Roma are doing
is playing brass music.
So the man in the white hat is
Marko Markovich from the Boban
and Marko Markovich Brass
Band in Southern Serbia.
But the first person listed there
is Goran Bregovic, I'll be talking
about him later, as a
non-Romani appropriator of music
who made Balkan music
popular in his film scores.
So we'll be looking at films,
we'll be looing at festivals.
I'm giving you a little
taste of what's to come
in the first five minutes.
So where do we find
quote Gypsies these days?
We find Gypsies in the New York
Gypsy Festival which is now,
I think, in its 11th year.
And every year the Statue of Liberty
plays a different Romani instrument.
But this festival over the years
has had fewer and fewer Roma,
so this is a trend
I'll be talking about,
"Gypsy" music without Roma, okay?
So if you have their music, and
other people are playing it,
and people don't know much about it,
why do you really need Roma anyway?
Another group, Gogol Bordello,
who coined the term "Gypsy Punk"
as a genre, headed by the
former DJ Eugene Hutz,
they became really famous and
they've crossed over not only
to world music audiences
but to pop music audiences.
So they perform at
festivals like Coachella
and the biggest festivals in Europe.
And they're no longer
even world music.
When they started out, Eugene Hutz
claimed he was one-fourth Romani
from Ukraine.
People in the New York Community
of Roma said "not really, no."
But as he got more famous everyone
sort of has to agree with him
because he's the guy with the gigs.
He's the one who has the contracts.
Everyone wants to work with him.
So now many more members of his band
are even claiming that they're Roma.
So one of the paradoxes
I'm talking about is
that in the music scene it's a
cache, it's a step up, to be Roma.
But outside the music scene it's
absolutely low-class status.
And this is the paradox
that Roma are admired
for their music but
reviled as people.
So I'll be introducing the
political situation of the music.
Madonna also got involved in
Romani music in her Sticky
and Sweet Tour in 2008/2009.
She actually invited Eugene
Hutz to perform with her,
the guy from Gogol
Bordello, but he was too busy.
And we lobbied Eugene to
substitute other people for him
because other Roma should
get a break in their career.
And, finally, Madonna agreed
to invite the Kolpakov Trio,
which actually includes
one Jewish member.
The violinist Arkady Gips is from
Ukraine, living in Columbus, Ohio.
He's played Romani music quite
a lot, and the Roma wanted him.
So on Madonna's tour you
had a 75-year-old guitarist,
the uncle of the young guitarist.
And this is unusual for Madonna.
But did she do anything
for Romani music?
Well, people heard the music.
She did in Bucharest, Romania.
She put down her guitar
and asked for quiet.
And she asked the audience,
"Do you love gypsy music?"
"Yeah, we love Gypsy music."
"I'm so happy you love gypsy music."
And then she said, "But I'm so
upset that you don't like Gypsies."
And then she was booed
by 60,000 people
in the stadium she
was performing in.
And the international
headlines were,
"Madonna doesn't understand
anything about our gypsy situation."
What did she do?
Well, she was lobbied
by the musicians backstage
to say something.
So she tried, but failed.
And then post-concert, she
sold one shoe at an auction
and donated it for a Romani cause.
So that's the sum total of Madonna.
But she's very important because
she actually included the music.
And then, of course, we have Borat.
If you remember that film where 95%
of the music was Balkan
Romani music,
and the film itself was staged in
Glod, Romania, in southern Romania,
a Romani village where the villagers
themselves did sign releases
for $10 a day because they knew
this was a good income for them.
But they had no idea they would
be pictured as Kazakhstanis
in bestiality positions,
incest-type scenes.
And they actually tried to sue Sasha
Cohen as well as many other people
in this film tried to sue him.
But nobody actually can
win against Sasha Cohen
and his Hollywood legal team.
Another woman who was featured
in that film, Esma Redzepova,
and she's performing tonight.
If you are all free you
will not be disappointed.
This is a legend of Romani
music from Macedonia,
and she will be performing at the
Millennium Stage at 6 p.m. tonight.
She also sued Sasha
Cohen because her --
the song that was used in the
film was on a Dutch label,
but she had a clause, she's very
smart, unlike a lot of other Roma
who actually don't have the legal
background to put these clauses
in their contracts, or they
don't have contracts at all.
She had a legal clause in her
contract with the Dutch firm
that said if it's used, her
music is used in a film,
she had to give personal permission.
And they did not.
The film just gave it.
So she was able to
recover some money
from the Dutch film,
not from Sasha Cohen.
And another recent thing is
Jason Derulo's hit "Talk Dirty,"
which used a saxophone riff,
which many Balkan Roma listened
to and said, "Oh, my god.
That sounds like Udi Yunakov or some
of our famous saxophone players."
It was definitely a
Balkan saxophone riff.
But, actually, it was taken from
Balkan Beat Box, a group composed
of Americans and Israelis, no Roma.
But the saxophone player,
Ori Kaplan,
in the group took lessons
from Udi Yunakov.
Actually, he's one of the
National Heritage Fellows
and you've seen him
here in Washington.
Udi lives in New Jersey, and
Ori took lessons for him.
But Ori took his music,
put it on this album,
and then when Jason Derulo
needed to license it,
it didn't involve Uri at all.
So there's Uri's music
but without Uri anymore.
And where else are
Gypsies these days?
Well, we can see Gypsies on
television in reality shows.
If you know the history
of this particular show,
it started in England as
My Big Fat Gypsy Wedding .
It got the largest viewership
of the BBC channel it was on.
It's a sensational show, emphasizing
violence, sexuality, teen marriages,
conflict in the society, and
it isn't even about Gypsies.
It's about Travelers or people who
have intermarried in England, Roma,
and Travelers, and even
groups that were paid
to stage these exotic-type rituals.
And so we have, basically --
this is the information that
the public knows about Roma.
And then the TLC took
it up in America
and made the American version
using families from the south
in Texas and Mississippi.
They, again, were paid
to do exaggerated type
of rituals and violence.
Then the National Geographic
Channel took up this kind
of craze for Gypsy reality TV.
We thought maybe it would
be more educational.
They even tried to
appear educational
by putting a Romani
glossary on their website.
And they asked scholars
for endorsements.
Of course we were very,
very, very suspicious.
I'm not Romani myself,
but I work with Roma
and basically people
ask you for endorsements
of Gypsy projects all the time,
and you have to be
really, really careful.
So you can tell this is, again,
sensational about fortunetelling
scams.
This is about the Kalderash
Group, a family in New York.
But, again, they were paid
to exaggerate their customs,
to fight on camera on purpose.
Okay. So, in addition, there's an
entire network of DJs doing sampled
and digitized Roma music which
they take from Balkan groups
and they have trademarked the name.
It is a, under trademark,
BalkanBeats.
And this is a whole
network of hundreds of DJs.
They started in Western Europe
and now they've gone to America
and Japan, Australia, and Mexico.
It's very big.
So I'll be talking about
this scene as well,
the kind of sampled
world of Balkan music.
And then here in New York
we have many different clubs
that have this kind of music,
sometimes mixed with
live Romani music.
But a lot of sampled music where
you don't need Roma anymore.
So just to review, basically,
I am talking about this paradox
that Roma are revered for their
music, yet reviled as people.
And historically the stereotype
about Gypsies is two-pronged.
One may appear to be positive
because it's about romanticism,
musicality, talented people
who don't need to work,
who sit around the fire
every day enjoying music.
It's a stereotype that is totally
fantasy and it goes hand-in-hand
with the negative stereotype
of criminality
and don't trust these people
and they will steal from you.
So I would say even, and, of course,
stereotypes have been
studied by scholars.
We know that the positive and
the negative are intertwined.
This is very true for
African Americans.
Not everybody is a
basketball player.
Very, very important to look
at positive stereotyping
and the damage that it does.
And I don't even call it positive,
but in the literature you call it.
And I mentioned already
the name issue
that I'm not using Gypsy except when
I have to for the marketing label,
and that's actually
what I'm studying.
The other labels, Tsigan,
which is tsigganos, Tsigane,
in many different European
languages, those --
that's also a false label because
it comes from the word "Athinganoi"
which is from a Byzantine
heretical sect,
and those were not
related to Roma either.
That word is also a
putdown in many, many Balkan
and Slavic romance languages.
Okay. So what are we talking about
-- just a little bit of history?
We're talking about Roma as an
Indian diaspora from South Asia.
Linguistic evidence has led us to
tie the Romani language to Sanskrit,
and even to modern-day
Hindi, and the diversity
of Romani subgroups even in
earlier migration, but definitely
in the current-day diaspora.
Okay? So some people ask
what does unite Roma?
Well, if they speak the Romani
language they can understand
each other.
But only half the world's Roma
speak Romani because it wasn't
to their advantage in some places
to continue their language.
Some Roma passed out
of that category.
Some were forced by
governments, schools,
to abandon their language,
to leave it.
Okay? So even nomadism and
sedentarism is a complicated issue.
Not all Roma are nomadic,
and even those
that are nomadic might have
been forced to move due to wars,
due to evictions, due to prejudice.
So there are Roma, for example, in
the Balkans that have been sedentary
for hundreds of years and
don't relate well to nomadism.
Or they might be seasonal
nomads or musical nomads
because they find their craft.
Metal craft workers perhaps
would take a seasonal route in --
certainly we have evidence of Roma
in the Middle Ages taking their
forges, their blacksmithing tools,
from town to town to service people.
So Roma have been very integrated
into the economy of Europe
for hundreds of years as
metalworkers, horse doctors,
musicians, middlemen,
peddlers, some fortunetellers --
although not all groups --
offering amulets or advice.
You might say it's a folk psychiatry
before psychiatry was invented.
Some of the very tragic periods
of Romani history need
to be mentioned here.
Slavery in Southern Romania,
in Wallachia and Moldavia,
for 500 years where Roma were owned
by the church and by the nobility,
and traded at auctions,
selected and sorted according
to their populations
and their occupations --
the gold washers, the
agricultural workers,
the musicians, the horse dealers.
The Nazi period in which Roma
were singled out for extinction
and genocide just like Jews.
And now we know over a million --
well, half-a-million to
a million Roma perished.
And a lot of activism about
getting the recognition
of Roma in the Holocaust.
Our Holocaust Museum here in
America, when it first opened here
on the Mall, had a
Romani Board Member,
and then when that
person stepped down,
for over 10 years there was
no Romani person on the Board.
Just this year, Ethel Brooks from
Rutgers University was appointed.
So it's a constant battle
to get recognition of Roma.
Many other things during the
more recent Socialist period
such as taking the wheels off
of caravans of nomadic Roma,
making their music illegal,
banning their language,
banning Romani types of dress.
Many, many things can be listed.
Probably most striking would be the
forced sterilization or Romani women
in Hungary, Czechoslovakia,
Finland, Sweden, places in the West,
just like other indigenous
groups, the Sami,
and this has happened
certainly in America as well.
And still today we have the tracking
of Romani children
into special schools.
This means, assuming
that they are disabled
because perhaps they speak the
majority language with an accent
or just their dark skin, and putting
them into schools for the disabled
which is a track you
never get out of,
and you're not in an academic track.
And a very important case was
adjudicated in the town of Ostrava
in the Czech Republic
where they showed
that it was 27 times more
likely for a Romani child to end
up in a special school
than a Czech student.
And still, in the European
Court of Human Rights
that case failed the first time.
It only won on appeal.
So these are the kinds of battles
that Roma and allies are fighting.
And if you think the U.S.
is a little more open,
it is in some ways, just because
Americans are more private.
But still in the U.S., in
southern states there are quote
"gypsy crime units" attached
to police departments.
They're called Bunco Squads and they
are paid for by your tax dollars
and they assume that there are Roma
who do certain kinds of crimes,
and only those crimes are done by
Roma, and only Roma do those crimes.
So it's a real huge assumption and
it's a form of racial profiling.
And not to mention what I'd
call the entire erasure of Roma
from European history,
American history, and so on.
So today Roma is the
largest minority in Europe.
The majority actually
reside in EU states.
And they have some of the lowest
rates of social integration,
you can see here on the
PowerPoint, in healthcare,
education, all of the indicators.
But most striking, of
course, is employment,
how little employment there
are because of discrimination
and also Roma were
tracked out of skilled jobs
in the Socialist government.
All the streetcleaners, for example,
were Roma in Poland,
Bulgaria, Romania.
So after socialism, many
didn't have the skills.
And those that had the skills
were not allowed to assume jobs.
They're just cut out.
And there's tremendous prejudice
against Roma in Europe today.
When I do my field work, even
educated professors tell me, "Oh,
don't go to that Romani
neighborhood.
You'll be killed, you'll be raped."
Of course, they've never been
in that Romani neighborhood.
They don't know any Roma, but
they have the historic prejudices.
And then if I invite them,
they'll say, "Oh, my God.
This is an amazingly nice house.
I had no idea."
You know, contact really does help.
And the most upsetting
thing, of course,
is physical violence
and intimidation.
Lots of incidences of targeting
of Roma, burning down houses.
Many of these cases are
still in the courts.
Roma rarely get justice.
This has been compounded
these days by migration.
So after the wall came down in 1989,
many Roma, of course, wanted to move
to Western Europe for better
jobs, better opportunities.
And it turns out West Europeans
are pretty prejudiced, too.
So there's been a hysteria,
a panic, about the floods,
the migrations, of East Europeans.
You might know the Italian
fingerprinting incident a few years
ago where the Italian government --
Berlusconi decided to
fingerprint all Roma,
to have a database for criminality.
This is so reminiscent
of World War II.
Okay? Can you imagine that,
an entire ethnic group?
There have been expulsions of EU
citizens, who have the right to work
in Western Europe,
back to Eastern Europe.
And outside the EU, in places like
Kosovo where it is really not safe
for Roma to be there, there
are expulsions back to Kosovo
of children, families who have
raised an entire generation
in Western Europe.
There are continuing
demonstrations against Roma.
It's a very tense situation.
And you might remember the
Greek "Blond Maria" incident
where a blond six-year-old was found
in a Turkish Romani settlement.
Pardon me, a Greek
Romani settlement.
And the -- when the police
saw her they assumed,
because she's blond,
that she was kidnapped.
So this is a really old
European stereotype,
you know, stolen by the Gypsies.
And actually when they
investigated -- it took a long time,
and all the media was about
the "abducted Maria," okay,
"blond Maria abduction" narrative.
When they found out what happened,
it was actually a Bulgarian
Romani family who was albino
who was working for
better wages in Greece
and the Greek Romani family offered
to watch the kids and raise them
because it's a better standard,
even though it looked pretty bad
to the police when they
saw the "blond Maria."
The Bulgarian family had
worse standard of living
and left their child
there voluntarily,
to be raised by a higher
class Romani family.
But the ramifications of
this incident were terrible.
Even as far as England, Roma, Romani
chilcren in England were going
to school and being told,
"Oh, well, you know,
do you have a blond
sister in your basement?"
You know, "Did you
steal my blond sister?"
Terrible types of ramifications.
So here's some photos of some
of the things that are going on.
The Hungarian Guard, which was
actually banned, is an informal part
of the Jobbik Party which sits
in the Hungarian Parliament,
a xenophobic party that patrols
villages to keep Gypsies out.
And they are using Nazi
symbolism and it is quite scary.
And there have been
anti-Romani protests everywhere.
This happens to be
one from Bulgaria.
So now back to music.
What does music have
to do with politics?
Well, music never operates
outside of the political sphere.
It is actually one of the realms
where Roma have some control.
But what I'm going to show is that
this control is being contested
in the commercial markets by
a lot of non-Romani forces.
So I wanted to show you a
little bit about the music
in some traditional
Romani communities --
that kind of music that you won't
see on the commercial stage, okay?
So I'm going to be looking
at insider/outsider
boundaries and so on.
So here are some Romani settlements
in -- this one is in Bulgaria,
in a Western Thrace, and
this is a wedding from 1990.
And this is another wedding from
1984, in Western Thrace as well.
Roma communities coalesce
around music.
It is a very important
performative means
to show your family solidarity,
your extended kin networks,
how you are allied, and, of course,
the artistry of the music itself.
Plus gender roles are
extremely important.
Women are very much
in charge of rituals.
They have knowledge that they
impart to the younger generation,
to tell them what to do when.
These women are bringing gifts in
Macedonia to the bride's family,
and those gifts will
actually be opened one by one,
and in public people will
announce who they came from,
how much they cost, and
where this person is located.
So this diaspora of family
security is very important.
So let's look at a few
videos of these very short.
[ Film: Singing and
sounds from the crowd ]
So we are in Macedonia,
in Suto Orizaro,
one of the largest Romani
neighborhoods outside
of Skopje known as Sutka.
And these are the groomswomen
in a wedding bringing gifts
to the bride's family
with zurla-tapan
which is a historic
Romani instrument.
In fact, it's been a monopoly of
Roma for 500 years until recently,
when non-Roma are learning it.
And it's an outdoor
procession type of instrument.
[ Music ]
This is the henna party
for the bride.
You could see henna on a round
tray with red gauze on top of it.
[ Music ]
Okay. So let me go on.
Just going to give
you a little taste.
So, back to my argument about music.
This is one type of very historic
and contemporary Romani music
that you will not find
at any Western festivals,
or even on CDs readily available.
But it is very much a
part of Balkan Roma life.
Here's another wedding
in Sutka, Macedonia.
And now we'll look at
some dancing on the day
of the henna party for the bride.
These are Muslim Roma.
Henna is actually used by Eastern
Orthodox in Greece as well.
It's a vegetable dye that
you put on the bride's hair.
[ Music ]
You can see the predominance
of women dancing
and male instrumentalists.
So there are segregated roles.
[ Music ]
Okay. And here's a bride
from Sutka, Macedonia.
And now we'll see a scene
from the bride's day.
Weddings in 1990 were
about five days long.
Now they're only two days long.
But this is the Saturday
of the wedding.
The bride is in the middle.
And her type of solo dancing,
cocek, is very modest.
It is related to belly
dancing, but no skin is used.
And she's surrounded by her family.
[ Music ]
So here you can see actually
a little solo performance
of cocek at a banquet.
Again, this type of movement
is considered beautiful.
Girls practice it, women
treasure it, men are encouraging.
But the very same movement
before strange men
in a bar would be considered
very, like a prostitute.
It would be very unacceptable.
Absolutely not.
So it's not the movement
itself, but the context.
>> Sani Rifati: Who said that?
[laughter]
>> Carol Silverman: That's
my colleague Sani Rifati.
I was going to introduce him before.
But he came in late.
Activist from Kosovo
now living in Berlin.
And we work together.
And he'll have some comments
later I'm sure [laughter].
There may be other activists
in Roma in the audience,
and I'd love your comments.
Okay [inaudible comment
from audience, laughter].
So Roma from the Balkans
have migrated, okay?
As soon as they could,
even in the 1960s
in the Yugoslav Guest Worker
Program, they were going
to Australia, Germany,
Austria, America.
But more recently, many Roma have
left since the fall of Yugoslavia.
And so I'm following
Roma around the world
because the music is
very much unified.
People listen to the same music.
People have the same
hits every new summer.
And so this is a party
I went to in Dusseldorf.
I was visiting Sani's cousins,
and 2 to 3 thousand Roma gather
for these parties in Western Europe.
Now the thing to remember is that
this is a Romani community event.
But maybe next door is a bar with a
DJ playing Romani music for Germans
that have nothing to do
with the Roma next to them.
So it's a really separate scene even
though maybe all non-Roma know is
the festival or the bar.
There's an active Romani
migration scene, diaspora,
in Western Europe and America.
So this party -- in fact,
the drummer tonight is
from [foreign placename], this
band that I saw in Dusseldorf.
So we're going to see a
wonderful band tonight.
And another branch of the Macedonian
Romani diaspora is in New York City.
So I've worked with them since
the 1980s, and they've been
in the city actually since the '60s.
And that's a very, very active
scene, hundreds of families.
They live in that neighborhood.
It used to be an Italian
neighborhood.
Yes.
>> Sani Rifati: Carol, I'm sorry.
But really I have to jump --
>> Carol Silverman: Yes.
>> Sani Rifati: previous --
>> Carol Silverman: Okay.
>> Sani Rifati: in Dusseldorf --
>> Carol Silverman: Yes, okay.
>> Sani Rifati: I live now in
Berlin, and I am working and trying
to collaborate these
Roma NGOs, so-called.
So one of the things is
Roma are very determined
to have a party just for us Roma.
And really they are determined
because of this global
Gypsy phenomenon.
And they're disgusted
with this marketing
and colonizing the Gypsy image.
And so, for me, working for
all these years with you
and producing Roma festivals,
I think it's important
to do a gathering and for
Roma and for the outsiders
because really then you
have a dialog or no.
>> Carol Silverman:
Yeah, I understand.
>> Sani Rifati: But because of this
phenomena, it's so much colonized,
the image and the culture and in
the meantime the Roma feel they're
losing their identity.
And it's important to
gather in one place.
For example, in San
Francisco, you have gay
and lesbian bars, for example.
But, and, you see, those are
places safe for them to be there.
And this is what is now coming out
from this Roma event in Dusseldorf.
>> Carol Silverman: Yes.
I think that's a very
important point,
that communities do need places
to share their own culture.
But there should be
maybe other places
where there's interaction
across ethnic lines.
And so, you know, we're trying --
I would say it would be good
to do both types of things.
But I can certainly say that the
people running the festivals don't
care about Romani communities,
and that's my critique
because I'm non-Roma and I feel like
I need to work with my own people
and present a critique of it, okay?
So in the Bronx, they have
parties and so on just
like in Dusseldorf,
just like in Macedonia.
Many of the musicians play
in mixed bands, so Bulgaria,
Macedonia, quite a number of bands.
The events sort of look the same,
but they're in banquet halls
and you can't really do
it in front of your house.
But they try.
They have some kind of acoustic
music in front of the house.
You can see one event here, I'll
play one or two, from New York.
[ Music ]
So some of the older
women do wear shalvari,
the traditional Muslin 10
meters of pantaloon costume.
[ Music ]
And this is very early
in the wedding,
so only the close females
are dancing.
The woman leading is
the groom's mother.
And I'll just go on to
show one other wedding
with an amplified band.
Oops, this did not catch.
Let me go back.
[ Music ]
[ Music and Singing ]
Okay. So now I'm going to move
into the commercial markets.
You've seen a little bit
about different kinds
of Romani communities.
So only a few bands from
the Balkans have made it
into you might say the world music
market, have been successful.
But when non-Roma kind of see them,
they sort of think every Romani
orchestra back in the village is
like benefitting from
a festival in Belgium.
And that's really a
false impression.
Only a few bands get hired over
and over again in the West.
So this Balkan Trafik Festival that
I mention, had three brass bands.
Two of them were from South Serbia,
this one, Boban and Marko Markovich,
Ekrem Mamutovich from
like just 10 miles away.
And why did they need
to have two bands?
Because they staged a
Balkan brass battle.
Again, the promotors
figure out gimmicks in order
to present these bands in a new way.
So I'll get back to that later on.
And a third band from
Macedonia, the Braka Kadrievi,
half of whom actually
live in Belgium, anyway.
So it was cheap to hire them.
Now brass music is part
of Balkan tradition,
but only in certain places.
So this is in Southern
Serbia in a Serbian wedding
where Romani musicians played.
So it is active, but it's
actually declining in some parts.
But you wouldn't know that if
you looked at a Western festival
where all you see is brass.
And also in Eastern Macedonia
you do have brass bands.
But due to this man, Goran Bregovic,
brass has become the defining
genre of quote "Gypsy music."
And he's a non-Romani man from
Bosnia of mixed background, Serbian,
who worked with the filmmaker Emir
Kusturica and wrote the film music.
But actually took it
from Romani sources
and put his name as
the copyright owner.
So he is absolutely hated and
reviled as a thief by most Roma.
They call him an appropriator
and a thief,
and yet he got the top
billing in Belgium.
And he makes more money
than any Romani band.
His fees are now about
30,000 euros for his show.
He doesn't like appear
just for a little while.
He needs his whole show.
And he appeared at a Guca Brass
Band Festival, which is a festival
of competition of the
best brass bands, okay?
So he's really loved by
non-Romani audiences,
and they even mistake him as Roma.
They call him the, you know,
Ambassador of Romani Music.
But he's not.
So I'm drawing attention to
what I'm calling the dialog
between celebratory and anxious
narratives of world music
that Steven Feld has written about.
And celebratory narratives
tend to look at appropriation
and exchange as a win-win situation.
All you're doing is providing new
creativity, new artistic impetus.
What could be bad about it
when we're all sharing
each other's culture?
The anxious narratives
-- of course I'm going
to critique the celebratory
-- but the anxious narratives,
I would critique some of them, too,
because some of the
anxious narratives are
about purity of music.
We should keep things pure.
And I don't subscribe
to that at all.
Romani music has never been pure.
Romani music has been an economic
commodity; has always been given
and taken by neighboring peoples.
But I do subscribe to the
anxious mentality when we talk
about the political economy.
What are the terms of the
trade when you exchange music?
Who is profiting?
Who is setting the terms of
those contract or no contracts?
Who's in charge of getting the
gigs, of dividing the money?
The other thing is that
"hybridity" has been used a lot
to valorize any type
of cultural exchange,
that something mixed is always good.
It destabilizes these
old kind of categories,
the binaries that we
have, that mixtures
and borders are inherently good.
But I would say that there's a
very healthy critique of hybridity.
Hybridity is also a
marketing category.
It's been used to actually put
a stamp on the earlier category
that valorized ethnic
music as authentic.
Like ethnic music comes from
kind of stable communities
that have their real folklore,
their real traditions.
That was the earlier phase
of world music marketing
in like, you know, the '80s.
But by the '90s, now you
see marketing that says
if it's hybrid it must be authentic.
So they hybrid becomes
the authentic.
And I think we have to be suspicious
of all of these marketing labels,
especially because hybridity
has actually been used
to discredit Gypsy music
in the scholarship.
Serbian scholars have said they
don't play real Serbian music.
They just play their version
with some kind of, you know,
Eastern ornaments or some
corrupted type of rhythms.
So, again, hybridity is
not inherently liberating
or progressive.
It has to be seen in its context.
So I'm actually analyzing
how decisions get made
about releasing Gypsy music
to non-Roma by looking
at the producers themselves.
So one of the biggest production
houses is in Germany, Asphalt Tango,
and they still do the old
types of stereotypes --
exotic, sexual, passionate,
dangerous,
from far away, maybe peasants.
Again, either they are
authentic or hybrid as authentic.
They picture Roma on their
CD covers as either villagers
or living in mud or with animals.
And they stage what I called
before the Balkan Brass Battle
with two huge brass bands,
Boban Markovich from Serbia
and Fanfare Ciocarlia as Romania.
And the way they staged
it is to take this group,
which does come a village,
from a village,
so you could call them peasants.
That's okay.
But they stage Boban
Markovich as cowboys.
So it was the cowboys
versus the peasants.
So they wore cowboy hats, and
this is how they were portrayed,
and it was a kind of almost
violent type of thing on stage.
In fact, one of the stagers
told me they were supposed
to take their trumpets, go back to
back, walk three paces, turn around,
and then play at each
other like it's a duel.
So, again, they're hinting
at kind of violence.
>> Sani Rifati: They
got that from Americans?
>> Carol Silverman: Yes.
So these questions I've been
asking are about representation,
about hybridity, about who
benefits from the popularization
of Balkan Gypsy music
and the economic context
in hierarchies of power.
And I'm going to end
with two other strands.
And this is back to the DJs.
So the BalkanBeats trademark
came from this particular fellow,
I'll go back to that, Robert Soko,
who's an ex-pat from Yugoslavia,
Bosnian, living in Berlin.
And now there's a network
of hundreds of DJs.
You can see some of the posters.
They use Romani words without
really understanding what they mean.
They're talking about
drunken parties.
Again, a lot of these sort
of stereotypes of Roma
who just know how to
have a good time.
End of story.
Okay. And here he is DJing and
this is the Lido in Berlin.
He has a monthly party and
it's very well attended.
This was 300 people
waiting outside at 3 a.m.
So it's very well attended.
And you can't use the name
without involving Robert Soko.
So these are -- this is
what the scene looks like.
It has expanded to America.
Kafana Balkan is in San
Francisco, Mehanata in New York.
There are some clubs
in Chicago I went to.
There's a healthy Scene in Mexico,
Japan, and Australia as well.
All of these DJs are non-Roma, okay?
There's maybe one Roma I found in a
Vienna club, and he was the busboy
in the club and heard the music and
started dancing, and the DJ said,
"Oh, you know how to dance?"
He said, "Well, this is my music!"
from the Balkans.
So they showed him
how to do some DJing.
But he's not one of
the ones who travels.
So let me just show you
what the scene looks like.
[ Singing ]
[ Music ]
Okay. So some of the DJs are
willing to do some research
and they do some really creative
things in terms of their artistry
and the weaving together,
the back beats and so on.
But others are basically curators.
They just take Goran Bregovic
tunes, the man I mentioned before
who wrote the film scores
with a lot of brass music.
And they kind of play the same
thing over and over again.
And most striking is that
they don't really know
that there are Roma living in
a neighborhood next to them,
maybe having parties or doing
a different kind of music --
wedding music -- whole
other kinds of Romani music.
If you look at their visuals, the
DJs rely on historical stereotypes.
These, you know, a lot of skin,
women, words like Gypsy dance party,
[Mistores?], which means good.
But that's the DJs name.
The Gypsy sounds -- even their names
of the DJs are all about Gypsy,
Gypsy -- Gypsy sound
system, the Gypsy box,
the Tsiganisation Project.
Remember that word "tsiganisation"
because it's very problematic.
This woman, a woman actually in --
>> Sani Rifati: Why [inauduble] --
>> Carol Silverman: -- Slovenia --
>> Sani Rifati: -- in Sega?
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: Why
don't you translate it?
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
I did before you came.
>> Sani Rifati: Oh.
>> Carol Silverman: Okay.
This woman calls herself
Gipsy Jungle, okay,
and has the brass sticking out the
jungle again, you know, uncivilized.
Many use visuals from the former,
you know, former Soviet times,
the old cars, the old trains, a lot
of brass, accordions, and so on.
This DJ made a symbol
called the trumpet-nikov.
He combined the Kalashnikov
and the trumpet.
And to me that's pretty problematic.
I asked him if it had
anything to do with guns.
He said, oh, no.
It doesn't have anything
to do with guns.
It's about the song "Kalashnikov,"
which Goran Bregovic wrote.
And the song is about guns.
But there's certainly a
violent implication there.
And these are some young
guys who don't have any money
and actually lose money
on their projects.
But they call themselves
the Tsiganization Project,
and remember that word
because I'm going to be talking
about now the highest paid
DJ, Shantel from Germany,
who has a very illustrious career.
He does about 250 shows a year.
These are all his CDs.
He's very, very, very famous.
He doesn't take part in
the BalkanBeats Network
because he doesn't even need them.
He doesn't need that
word BalkanBeats.
But he wrote a song called
"Disko Partizani" in 2007,
and the refrain is "Tsiganizatia."
But you have to understand
that Tsiganizatia,
which means Gypsyfication, is used
by right-wing xenophobic parties
to say our country is
becoming too Gypsyfied.
Let's get rid of those folks.
So, again, even hearing that
word is very, very problematic.
But he's using it as
the refrain of his song.
So I'm coming to the end now
and I'd like to start where --
to end where I started, talking
a little bit about celebrities.
So here is our friend Vadim
Kolpakov with his 74-year-old uncle
and the Jewish violinist
on the Madonna tour.
And Vadim tried very, very
hard to get Madonna interested
in Romani music, and he
made this film to thank her.
And so you can see a little
bit about what happens
when Romani music is taken
into pop culture, okay?
And after that I will take
questions and thank everybody.
So this will be the last video.
[ Music ]
So that's Vadim dancing
Russian Romani style.
Very similar to Central European.
[ Music ]
>> Film: Madonna, we thank
you for giving us opportunity
to present Romani musical
culture arond the world.
[ Music and Singing ]
[ Music ]
>> Carol Silverman: Okay.
Well, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
And I would love to
hear your comments
because this is a work in progress.
I am working on this new project,
so if you have any experience
with Gogol Bordello or any of
the genres I'm talking about,
I would love to hear about it.
And we also have other very
qualified people in the audience
to help answer questions.
Yes, your hand was up first.
>> Audience member: I'm
wondering if it's a question
of the zurla [inaudible],
the Roma and the --
>> Carol Silverman: So, the
zurla or zurna was banned
in Bulgaria during the
Socialist period in 1984.
So between '84 and '89 you
couldn't play that loud instrument.
It's the first one you heard.
That outdoor instrument
that's double-reeded.
And that was a Socialist
Government decision --
probably had input from
Moscow of targeting Muslims
and Roma, so Turks and Roma.
So the Romani language,
Turkish language, circumcisions,
Romani costume, Turkish
costume, and zurla were outlawed.
But after 1989 it's now free.
So Roma are playing
the zurla everywhere.
My point was that zurla is
not found in the festivals
for non-Roma if you wondered that.
Yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: Carol,
under the Communism,
most of these Eastern European
countries would really sponsor
and finance their national
instrument from the country.
Given that zurla comes from India,
it was foreign to Bavarians.
But in the meantime compared
to [inaudible] these instruments
were the Romance diaspora,
not the ethnic Bavarians or
other groups in the Balkans.
So many instruments were their
music preserved no matter what.
Even [inaudible].
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
Zurla players, even when it was
illegal and you could go to jail
for playing it, were playing
it in private ceremonies
with somebody posted on the roof
to look out for police coming.
Okay? So if you make
something illegal,
that doesn't necessarily
mean it goes away.
It goes underground, and
actually becomes more important
to people's life.
Bulgarian wedding music
was also prohibited,
and people went to jail for it.
And that survived underground
as well.
Yes.
>> Female audience member: I'm
just curious if you can comment
on production and representation
issues
in the movie Gypsy
Caravan [inaudible].
>> Carol Silverman: Mm-hmm.
Okay, so the movie,
The Gypsy Caravan:
When the Road Bends by Jasmine
Dellal, that is a documentary film
about the North American
Tour Gypsy Caravan.
I was on that tour.
I'm in the movie.
I have a very, like
two seconds in it.
The first tour was in 1999
and the second tour was 2001.
And Jasmine mostly
documented the tour in 2001,
but she included the band
Taraf De Haidouks from 1999.
So when you watch the film
you think it's one tour,
but it's actually two
tours combined.
So the film includes
amazing Romani music
from Romania Taraf De Haidouks,
Antonio El Pipa from Jerez
in Spain, several other groups.
And I think it gives a good idea of
the backstories of these musicians.
There were some problems with the
films just in translation and so on.
But I do think, if I'm -- it is the
film you're asking about, right?
Okay. It does give a good biography
of the musicians -- Esma Redzepova.
is in that film as well
-- of their backstories.
But, yeah, it got some distribution
and I'm glad it was made, mm-hmm.
>> Sani Rifati: I was at the --
I worked very closely
with Jasmine in that film.
And this is exactly what Carol
talked entirely presentation.
And I had an agreement
with her not to market
that with just another Gypsy title,
you know, to capture the audience.
And guess what?
She did exactly that because the
producer said "if you want really
to be successful then you
have to title it Gypsy."
And I really fell apart with
Jasmine since then with --
are not any more good friends,
because this is another colonization
of the -- trying to
market the wild Gypsy.
So this is really a
serious part of it.
Yeah.
>> Carol Silverman: Anybody else
have any comments or questions?
Yes, thank you.
>> Male audience member: I guess I
would say just the other side is,
you know, I was looking
in here up in early 2000,
and I think it was really popular
like in [inaudible]
is the techno music.
And after a while it's just
really excruciatingly boring.
And so I'm just wondering if there
was this need to do something
that just seemed less
boring and different.
>> Carol Silverman: Well, of course
you know music tastes are personal.
What's boring to you might be
really interesting to other people
because it puts them in a trance
or really gives them a groove.
But I will say that in
the BalkanBeat scene --
I'm talking about the dance
clubs with remixed music --
many of those DJs were in techno
and house music before they
moved into the Balkan scene.
And in the 1990s the
techno scene was kind of,
just kind of going along,
not really getting speed.
And the Balkan had this new
energy, the melodies are different.
And that's what caught
people's attention.
So I do think that the
introduction of Balkan music
into the dance club scene
was a very historic moment
in capturing youth
audiences mostly in Germany,
Austria, Belgium, and so on.
And a lot of the DJs actually
learned about remixing Balkan music
because their audiences want it.
So the DJs actually moved over.
Shantel, Stefan Hantel, he's
from Germany, from Frankfurt,
he was a techno DJ,
not very distinguished.
And as soon as he started
doing Balkan stuff,
that's where he got his reputation.
So there is something
in what you're saying.
>> Sani Rifati: There is also
this huge scene in San Francisco
with this -- we can them techies.
Most of the young kids are
working for Silicon Valley.
And the [Cabana?] Balkans which
Carol showed in one of the photos,
the organizer brings his
[inaudible] and he's DJing,
and he's trying really
kind of to get --
and these people are
working very hard.
Probably they put in one
week 60 to 80 hours of work.
And then they got to party.
There is nothing going on.
They just jump up and down because
their life is so busy and so this is
for them like one outlet
to become like wild Gypsy.
So, mm.
>> Carol Silverman: I haven't
done too much on ethnographic work
with clubbers themselves,
but I've done a little.
And when I've interviewed
them and I said "what do you
like about the BalkanBeats?"
they usually say the
energy, the different kinds
of melodies, the variety.
So I think they're
looking for something new.
In Europe actually, the
BalkanBeats DJ's seen as going down.
In America it's going up.
It's going way up in
Mexico, Australia, and Japan.
So the markets change.
You know, Europeans
have had it longer.
They started it in the '90s.
America much, much later,
even 15 years later.
So that's what I'm studying now.
I'm looking for the new markets.
Yes.
>> Female audience
member: I just want to say
that yours is a space
that I'm familiar with.
The Roma and -- since you have
the opportunity to present here,
and you say with a German
audience in Heidelberg, yeah,
the [inaudible] center
for the [inaudible].
And one of the most
fascinating [inaudible]
that I found was a bringing together
of flamenco musicians and dancers,
the musicians and dancers
from [inaudible]
which was organized by the center.
It was really fascinating
to see the interaction.
>> Carol Silverman: Mm-hmm.
Yeah. A lot of Romani events do
like to show Roma from the diaspora.
And sometimes it works;
sometimes it doesn't musically.
There was a project, The Gypsy
Caravan Tour that you asked about.
A Rockefeller Grant was secured for
the second tour to have a project
between Musafir, which was
later retitled Maharaja.
That was the Rajasthani
Group and Antonio El Pipa,
again bringing flamenco and the
Rajasthani musicians together.
But that's problematic, too.
The Rajasthani musicians that
go around the world today
under the rubric "Gypsies,"
we don't really know
if they are Rajasthani musicians
from over a thousand years ago.
We don't really know what group
Roma came from, maybe Kabelias.
But the Rajasthani ones in Maharaja
and Musafir are Langa
and [foreign word].
They're nothing to do with
modern-day European Roma.
So all of this is hypothetical
and when I wrote the program notes
and I was the Educational
Coordinator
for the first Gypsy Caravan ,
and I tried to problematize this
in the notes, but the
producer said, oh, no, no.
Just say they're all one people.
So like the audience is hungry
to know about the unity of Roma,
but actually the musicians
like to talk
about the diversity,
and scholars as well.
Yes, you had your hand up, yeah.
>> Male audience member: Oh, yeah.
I just had a flashback.
I remember -- maybe you
all may remember this song
that is by singer Cher.
>> Carol Silverman: Cher?
>> Male audience member: Yeah,
the song called "Gypsies,
Tramps, and Thieves."
>> Carol Silverman: Yes.
>> Male audience member:
And I think it was a hit.
It definitely was a hit,
but it also perpetuated
that negative stereotype now
that I'm coming to this forum
and finding out, you know, how
the Roma community really feels
about their culture
being prostituted.
>> Carol Silverman: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, sure.
I mean, again, this is a very old
pattern of using Gypsies as, again,
thieves, tramps, or you know,
happy-go-lucky wanderers.
But not real people.
So kind of a fantasy thing.
Yes.
>> Female audience member:
So, I like Gipsy Kings Band.
Do you have any comments about them?
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
The Gipsy Kings band are
from Southern France.
And they founded a style of rumba
that took some from flamenco
and some from Sinti culture
and other types of Roma.
They were very important because
they were the first Romani band
to tour from the West into
Eastern Europe after 1989.
So they were at all the festivals.
The first like Roma festivals
in Bulgaria had the Gipsy
Kings, and they're still going.
They're a family band.
But, again, it's one
genre of Romani culture.
Again, some people may
object to their title,
but they know the word
"Gipsy" sells.
So there are, again, bands
that would self-stereotype
because they know they need to.
Yeah. And they have a really amazing
quality of music, absolutely.
>> Sani Rifati: And, actually,
their parents did the first
recording in New York in 1951.
>> Carol Silverman:
Oh, I didn't know that.
>> Sani Rifati: So it's [inaudible]
They brought them to New York,
that was their first recording.
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah, so,
I mean, there are families
in Southern France who have
done that kind of music
for a long time for insiders.
And they were the first group
to kind of break out in, again,
in the -- they got into
pop audiences which is --
the're even larger than
world music audiences.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Carol Silverman: Oh, okay, great.
Mm-hmm. Yes.
>> Male audience member:
I'm going to ask you --
this isn't remotely related
to the entire topic here.
But, Django Reinhardt and how
the phenomena of Gypsy jazz --
which has become a
genre like bluegrass --
>> Carol Silverman: Oh, yeah.
>> Male audience member:
They play swing tunes
on acoustic instruments,
same as [inaudible].
It seems like it's international.
There's probably a [inaudible].
>> Carol Silverman:
Yes, I'm sure there is.
>> Male audience member: How do the
Roma perc-- it's not going away.
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
>> Male audience member: Well,
how do the Roma perceive that?
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
"Gypsy" Jazz, again, is a genre
that comes directly
from Django Reinhardt.
So he was a Belgian guitarist.
I'm sure you know the history.
But Belgian guitarist who started
playing with jazz musicians
and brought some of his
Romani heritage into jazz,
and people imitate him now.
Not only his family but many
non-Roma and it's actually the most,
I would say, accessible
style of Romani music
because it's been around
a long time.
He lived in the '20s and '30s,
through the War, actually.
So "Gypsy" jazz has been on the
radar for non-Romani audiences
and many, many non-Roma
learn "Gypsy" jazz styles.
But the word itself --
he didn't coin the word,
the genre named "Gypsy jazz."
Many other people prefer to call
it Sinti jazz or Manouche jazz.
That's the name for themselves.
That's what they call it.
They're a subgroup of Roma in France
and Spain called Manouche
in Belgium as well.
And there's a very, very excellent
scholar getting her dissertation
at NYU writing about this, Siv
Lie, and she's going to be,
hopefully, publishing soon.
She's working with
Django's family today.
>> Male audience member:How do
the Roma feel about that, though?
>> Sani Rifati: Can I
talk about that, Carol?
>> Carol Silverman:
Yeah, sure, go ahead.
Yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: The "Gypsy"
jazz, actually, again --
we go back to this kind of how to
market the music and to sell it.
Actually the "Gypsy" jazz, I
would call it rather a Manouche.
That's the style that
Django Reinhardt invented.
What he did -- he used the -- given
that he was Manouche from France--
from the French in Belgium.
He used this style of the French
music, kind of like a waltz style,
an old Indian classic raga, okay?
And what was he notorious for?
He invented this style of la
pompa which means the pump.
And the emphasis --
>> Carol Silverman: Rhythm.
>> Sani Rifati: -- are on the
second beat and the fourth.
When you go one, two,
three, four, with a guitar.
They guitar sounds like a drum.
But now there is also a very
interesting phenomena coming
out from Europe.
Synthegenesis -- actually
not in the genre of music.
It's -- that is either
swing or jazz music
or it's a Manouche style
playing [inaudible].
It's trying to get somehow
through the music their identity
which they tend to kind of
differentiate themselves
from the Roma, especially
from the Balkans.
>> Carol Silverman: I would add that
according to Siv Lie's research,
that is now coming out
in her dissertation.
There are many Romani songs
that Manouche people
play only for themselves.
But when they go on stage
they'll play Sinti jazz.
But they have other repertoires
that they only use themselves.
So they distinguish
between what they use
for like selling their music
and what they have at home.
Many of the Roma don't distinguish.
In the Balkans they don't have any
secret songs or anything like that.
Whatever, you know, people want
they'll play at a festival.
So you have to look at
each group separately
and see how they manage
their repertoire.
Yes, Amy.
>> Female audience member: Let me
see if I can phrase this right.
So I've been somewhat
associated with some of this music
in my own American
way for my whole life.
And it's usually been in
really small groups of people.
And sometimes they'll give a huge
party and there'll be hundreds
of people, but they're
still mostly Americans.
But, again, you know, something like
the [inaudible] Balkan is 10 times
as many people listening to
music that I care a lot about
and I care about [inaudible].
>> Carol Silverman: And
that does widen audiences,
so it has one positive thing.
>> Female audience member: So what
I see is that we have this kind
of a public -- I mean, I
don't really just think
that is [inaudible],
but there is this kind
of public relations war going
on, in a sense, between people
who are perfectly happy to sell
something and appropriate it
without basically spending very
much time thinking respectfully
about where it comes from,
and people who are trying
to put some energy into that
respectful way of doing it.
And we don't necessarily
a lot of the time hang
out in the same places,
although some of us try to be
in multiple places so we
kind of see what's going on.
I'm kind of curious -- I've
know you for some years --
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
>> Female audience member: But
I'm curious over the question
of your life and Sani, you as
well, like have you seen --
what have you seen in
terms of forwarding
that respectful approach that's
been successful and what haven't.
Like, you know, I mean
it's not really a war.
We all want be --
>> Carol Silverman: Right, yeah.
>> Female audience member:
-- you know, together.
But --
>> Carol Silverman: Right.
And certainly I'm not against
the dissemination of Romani music
and more people listening to it.
But it would be nice if they
were informed and they knew
where Roma were involved
at some point or another.
I think that's important.
But I would say in our -- you
know, we do Balkan music and so on.
In the early years we to have
like "Gypsy" night at our camps.
I mean, that -- we
wouldn't have that now.
We were ignorant.
We just didn't know about
the label and so on.
Now things go along with
explanations, Roma are involved,
there's educational
materials available.
But on the -- but our scene may
be actually different from some
of the other scenes
I'm talking about.
So like I came across a brass
band in Portland, Oregon.
I'm from Oregon.
Where the guy sells gold
teeth during intermission,
and puts fake gold teeth.
I mean, first I saw him
with fake gold teeth,
and then the next time he
was selling gold teeth.
So he's like going in
the other direction.
So, in other words, just because
we have our group that try
to become more respectful, work
with Roma, spread the education,
that doesn't mean it has
a kind of global effect.
There's many different scenes and
you have to look at them separately.
>> Sani Rifati: Actually, I
mean, you know, Carol is a --
with Larry and many other friends --
>> Female audience
member: Yeah, yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: -- through America.
It's really the pioneers who
introduce this kind of culture
to Americans because people are
really, completely misinformed.
Everything is like completely like
so much all with the Gypsy fantasy.
>> Female audience Memeber: Right.
>> Sani Rifati: And that really --
this is what we see, the outcome.
>> Female audience
member: Yeah, yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: You know?
>> Female audience member: Yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: And
for us, for example,
we are trying still
to educate people.
For example, now in this --
one of the films she showed,
the Gypsy fest, we
tried really hard to --
Carol put really some proper
wording and the organizer --
they just simply don't
care because they're afraid
that they're going to lose audience.
>> Female audience member: Right.
>> Sani Rifati: And for us is very
important the educational aspect.
>> Female Audience member: Yeah.
>> Carol Silverman: Mm-hmm.
>> Sani Rifati: And so
there are some really lot
of stuff, in a lot of schools --
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: -- and institutions.
And now the book-writers
are contacting us, and --
>> Female audience member: So it's
growing, slowly, slowly, slowly.
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
I would also just add that --
>> Sani Rifati: But -- hmm?
>> Carol Silverman:
I would also just add
that Roma are extremely respectful
of non-Roma who take the time
to learn their music well, and learn
about its history and its context,
and maybe invite them
to collaborate.
It's -- that's the way
it should be, I think.
It's not like you shouldn't touch --
>> Sani Rifati: No.
>> Carol Silverman: -- music.
You're going to be
called an appropriator.
It's like -- figure
out what your role is.
>> Sani Rifati: Carol, we
had the project in 2010
with a brass band in San Francisco.
And now they stripped that band and
they have one band for the marches
and the other band is
called [foreign words].
>> Carol Silverman: Which
means in inspector of non-Roma.
>> Sani Rifati: Yeah.
>> Carol Silverman: So
they took this Romani word
for an outsider as their title.
>> Sani Rifati: And they --
>> Carol Silverman: They're owning
up to being outsiders, yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: [Inaudible]
you know?
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
>> Sani Rifati: And
then they invited --
>> Carol Silverman: Okay.
We have to stop.
>> Sani Rifati: And they
educate the audience.
Now even the --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Sani Rifati: -- now they
literally force you not
to use the word "Gypsy" anymore.
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah, mm-hmm.
Yeah. So there are ramifications.
>> Sani Rifati: Yeah.
>> Carol Silverman: You
can make a difference.
That's, I think, my point, mm-hmm.
>> Sani Rifati: And it's all these
young kids are getting [inaudible]
some information.
>> Carol Silverman: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: I want to thank
you all for coming and, of course,
thank Carol Silverman again
for doing a terrific lecture.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.